It's been sad that if Samsung agonists these didn't exist,
then we could say with ax something like perfect confidence that John Milton
could never have chosen.
Uh,
Samsung for a hero.
there's,
there's very little,
there's very little in the Samsung story that makes sense in terms of the larger
thematic patterns of Milton's major poems as,
as we have come to know them and think about paradise lost in paradise lost.
Milton struggled to justify the ways of God to men.
He attempted to make kids religion.
His faith has justifiable and as rational in a lot of ways as he possibly could
in paradise regained Milton Rewrote Christian history.
He wouldn't even further rewriting Christian history to scrub it.
Clean of the primitive and violent notion of sacrifice in the form of the
crucifixion.
Fallen man was redeemed.
We remember not because Christ was,
was sacrificed on the cross,
but because of a much more rational and arguably a justifiable cause,
man was redeemed quite simply because the son of God was able to resist the
temptations of Satan.
Man was redeemed because the sun was able to behave
rationally and,
and obedient lane.
And an unstated,
an unstated corollary here is that for paradise regained is that we can all,
we're all in a position to try to redeem ourselves.
And I think this is why Milton so scrupulously and carefully,
um,
refers to Jesus either as Jesus or the son,
the son of God and never and in paradise regained as,
as Christ.
Um,
of course we can't aspire to the status of Christ.
Uh,
which is this the,
the,
the Greek word for Messiah,
which merely means the anointed one.
That's something that we can't be,
but all of us as Satan knows,
all of us are sons of God.
Um,
we,
we all have the capacity to do pretty much,
uh,
what the son of God had accomplished in paradise regained.
Now when we approach Samsung agonists,
Ds,
we realized pretty quickly that we have to toss aside immediately any
expectation that Milton,
we'll be writing a theodicy and attempt to justify the ways of God.
I,
it's,
it's impossible to imagine the justice or the rationality behind the primary
actions of this poem.
And the first question that I think we have to ask ourselves is,
is what could possibly have possessed Milton to have chosen Samson this,
that,
that famous biblical hero for the subject of his final work.
I'm just going to ask you for a moment to think about Samson as he appears in
the Old Testament.
The book of judges,
I think all,
all,
uh,
biblical scholars agree that the story of Samson had its origins in a,
in a primitive and savage set as Samsung was a giant who slayed Philistines with
the jaw bone and who attached firebrands to the tales of foxes.
Um,
in order to set whole city's on fire and the,
and the writer of the judge's version of this tale,
which comes much later.
Of course then the original tail itself,
it's a folk tale.
The judges,
the judges version has done very little to cleanse the tale of what we can think
of as its savagery to transform the tail into anything that we might think
appropriate for holy scripture.
And if the Old Testament Samsung can be said to possess,
possess any virtues that we would feel comfortable recognizing as virtues,
it would have to be Samson's complete abstinence from wine.
And a while it goes without saying that we all applaud,
um,
Samson's abstemious snus surely this abstinence from wine isn't enough in and of
itself sufficient,
a sufficient cause for Milton to turn what is essentially a terrorist ogre into
the,
into an orthodox hero fit for a Christian poem.
Now look at the front of the handout.
Um,
this is where I've reproduced the end of the judge's version of the Samson
story.
And this is so,
this is,
uh,
according to the Hebrew Bible,
this is the Samson's climactic actions at the Philistine Festival of day gone.
Uh,
you'll remember the Samson has been blinded.
He's been humiliated and he's being forced to make sport for the Philistines.
It's a side show or the main show and Samson Colden to the Lord and said,
oh Lord God,
remember me,
I pray thee and strengthen me.
I pray thee only this once.
Oh God,
that I may be at once avenged of the Philistines.
For my two eyes.
And Samson took hold of them to middle pillars upon which the house stood and
upon which it was born,
of the one with his right hand and if the other with his left.
And Samson said,
let me die with the Philistines.
And he bowed himself with all his might and the house fell upon the Lords and
upon all the people that were there in
Samson,
praise to God.
No,
it's true.
He prays to God.
But what?
Look what he prays for us.
He's praying for vengeance only.
This once,
let me Yvette be avenged upon the Philistine Samsung praise and and enact that
can only be called a suicide.
And it has been called a suicide for thousands of years.
Now,
Samson brings the house down.
The dominant impulses here are suicide and revenge,
and by any ethical standard available to Milton,
this story has to be seen as as morally and ethically repugnant.
Now it's true that Milton does make some efforts to to clean the story up,
to purge the story of some of its most morally offensive elements.
And I think that's perhaps one of the reasons why you have all of that violent
rhetoric,
that language of purgation that I,
that I talked about in the last lecture,
but nonetheless,
we simply can't deny the fact that Samson does commit suicide and that the
suicide has this singularly satisfying effect of avenging the loss of Samson's
eyes.
And what is so amazing about this poem is the Samson's final action and action
that any right thinking Christian,
any right thinking anyone would would have to find ethically repellent.
This final action is it's approved of,
it's sanctioned,
it's sanctioned by God,
Samson's murderer,
his feelings,
his unseemly desire to get even all of these questionable motives are given a,
a vast divine blessing.
It's,
it's,
it's shocking expression of what for what Freud would call wish fulfillment.
This final work of Milton seems from,
from a theological point of view,
from the,
from the religious perspective to counter just about everything of Milton's that
we've read up to up to this point.
And that's because here every wish,
every desire,
all of those passionate and instincts that the,
the other works.
We're laboring so hard to suppress.
Um,
all of these wishes just get fulfilled in this,
in this poem.
Now I'm not at all suggesting that Samson agonists,
ds is wholly unrelated to Milton's other works and the,
that would be the last thing I would want to suggest.
Milton's,
obviously I'm imagining the final action of this poem in relation to the
climactic actions of his other two major works.
And he draws all three of his final works together by placing their central
actions at high noon.
At mid day in paradise lost,
um,
eve falls at noon and Milton told us simply,
this is on the handout,
but it's also on the board.
Milton tells us with exquisite economy she plucked she at
and with this extraordinary concision,
Milton narrated that act on earth that initiates the history of fallen man in
paradise regained Milton describes the action that works really to undo the
effects of Eve's fall.
And that's the Sun's resistance,
his,
uh,
his resistance to Satan's temptation as opposed to his,
his giving into it as you've had.
And in narrating this event,
Milton alludes to the grammatical structure of that narrative.
Crux from paradise lost and he employs another sentence of four monosyllabic
words,
two of them,
two of them active verbs he said,
and stood
what the,
what was the transgressive action in paradise?
Lost is,
is redeemed through what could be seen as the sun's motionless inaction.
His resistance to action,
or at least is resistance to any,
uh,
any form of heroic action as it is typically conceived.
Now in Samson agonist,
these Milton simply can't resist the opportunity to complete this triad of
momentous actions and he can't resist the,
this opportunity to remind his readers,
us of his other two great major poems.
So when Samson pulls down the pillars of the temple,
Milton describes that action with just with a closely related grant,
grammatical construction forwards,
two of them verbs.
He tugged,
he shook.
And I want you to pause just for a moment and to think about how shocking
when we consider this sequence,
how shocking that sentences with this final catastrophic action.
Milton seems to take back everything that the son of the son of God had
accomplished in paradise regained.
This has to be one of the most regressive conclusions in,
in all of,
in all of English literature,
the son of God,
a devoted all four books of paradise,
regained to resisting action,
resisting vulgar,
militaristic,
violent action.
He simply did nothing.
And he was so adamant in his resistance that that Satan was led.
You'll remember to cry out with complete exasperations what does now in this
world?
And the answer to that question was that the sun does absolutely nothing in this
world,
or he does absolutely nothing except obey the will of God.
But his climactic high noon action,
Samson seems it's amazing.
Sampson seems also to be obeying the will of God,
but his action has a much stronger resemblance to that transgressive act of,
of the willful.
Eve Eve had followed her own desire.
She had followed her own instinct when she made the fatal decision to eat the
fruit.
And here at the end of Milton's career,
it says,
if Milton,
we're allowing,
allowing himself to,
to rethink perhaps the theological implications of Eve's,
uh,
action.
It's as if Eve's act were being reimagined this time as as a heroic one.
Eh,
in this remarkable exercise,
him in wish fulfillment,
Sampson gets to perform his eve like transgression,
but,
but with the big difference,
with the magical blessing of,
of,
of divine sanction,
he tugged,
he shook,
he performs an action at least as transgressive as the leaves,
but it's not followed by any of the hideous consequences of Eve's plucking and
eating it.
It's as if Milton were saying to God,
only this,
only this once,
let an action as bold as eaves meet with your approval.
Yeah,
look at Milton's.
Milton's description of the destruction of the temple.
This is line 1,643 of Samson agonists,
ds.
And it's that the bottom of page 590 of the Hughes,
according to the,
according to the Messenger who reports the event,
uh,
Samson tells the assembled the assembled Philistines in the,
in the huge theater now of my own accord,
such other trial,
I mean to show you of my strength yet greater as with a maze sheller strike
shall strike all who behold this uttered straining all his nerves.
He bowed as with the force of winds and waters pent when mountains tremble,
those two Massey pillars with horrible conversion to and fro.
He tugged,
he shook till down.
They came and drew the whole roof after them with burst of thunder
and,
and Milton's language here of this thunderous trembling,
this horrible convulsion is the,
is essentially the language of uh,
of apocalypse.
He's imagining the scene of destruction as if it were something like something
akin to the end of the world and the destruction of the temple functions here.
It's as if it were a type or a forerunner of God's final destruction of the
world at the end of time.
Then now the Samsung story from the Old Testament is an event that clearly a co
that occurred before the son of God's redemption of man,
that,
that from the New Testament that Milton Milton depicts in paradise regained.
But there's some and some remarkable sense in which this text describes an event
in Christian history that happens after the events of paradise regained in a,
in a strange and inverted kind of way.
Samson agonist,
he's describes the fulfillment,
the culmination of the events that were,
uh,
that were laid out in paradise,
regained.
And,
and you can see that these last,
they'll the last three work seem to sketch in something like chronological
order.
Even though the stories they tell themselves they're not in chronological order,
they sketch in chronological order,
the outlines of Christian history,
she plucked,
she ate,
we have a representation of the fall,
he said,
and stood.
We have a representation of the redemption.
He tugged,
he shook.
We have something like a representation of the apocalypse and Samsung are going
to cities in some ways is imagining itself in terms of of the closure of a
larger thematic pattern in Milton's literary career and,
and the,
and the amazing thing is the,
the,
the astonishing thing about this final action is that it's so completely
transgressive from any ethical or theological perspective.
Look at line 1643 they're the first line.
I just read it the,
at the scene of the temple.
This is Samson now of my own accord.
Such other strength.
I mean to show you what my strength yet greater such other trial,
I mean to show you of my strength,
yet greater Samson is in no way here attributing as we think,
as we think he should.
He's not attributing any of his strength or any of his actions to God.
This is the,
you remember the son of God was always hungering to do the father's will.
He was attributing everything and rightly so to the father.
But Samson doesn't Credit Jehovah with anything here.
He's not even claiming to perform this action for the greater glory of God.
And,
and I think it's impossible.
It is possible to read this as a,
as an entirely personal act of revenge.
And,
and,
and I'm personally convinced that Milton is alluding and these lines to that
magnificent speech that Satan had made,
um,
just before the war in heaven.
This is the speech right after Satan had claimed to ab deal that he was self
[inaudible] self made by our own quickening power.
Um,
Satan had said to ab deal our presence,
our power,
our presence is our own.
Our own right hand shall teach us highest deeds and in claiming to make a show
of strength solely of his own accord.
And Milt Milton Samson and a lot of ways seems to be echoing Milton Satan and
he's,
he's reasserting Satan sublime.
But of course completely disastrous bid for something like an absolute self
sufficiency,
the D,
but there's a difference in the differences that Samson's claim to be entirely
self sufficient.
Yeah,
just meets with all of God's approval.
It's the,
it's the damnedest thing.
It's certain moments.
It almost seems as if the character of Samsung,
okay,
is the character of Satan simply rewritten as the good guy
now and reading Samsung agonists.
D's were,
we're witnessing something like an,
uh,
an incredible release from all of the laws and all of the constraints and all of
the divine ordinances that Milton had been representing for us throughout the
earlier works.
The,
the other poems from,
from comas on are all about the importance of the obedience to,
to law,
the obedience to divine law.
But Samson,
Samson agonists,
these is all about God's special dispensation to break the law.
Um,
I think about it.
Samson is permitted to break the divine law,
forbidding the marriage to a Philistine.
He does this twice and he's permitted to break the law that forbids the presence
of Hebrews at the festival,
at the Philistine Festival of day gone.
I'm Samson action.
Samson's action simply break through every conceivable legal and moral
constraints and,
and all of,
I mean,
why,
why does he get to do that?
All of Sampson's behavior,
I think has to ultimately to be laid at the door of God.
And in this case,
it's an unjustifiable or an irrational or inscrutable God.
Look at Samson's explanation of his first marriage.
He was married before the marriage to Dolly law and this was his marriage to the
woman of Timnah.
Look at line two 19 of Samson.
This is page five 57
and the Hebrews,
the Hebrews had a law against marrying outside of the tribe.
I'm still a big deal.
A lot many people would say,
and the chorus asks Samson why it is he doesn't marry a Hebrew wife.
I love this question.
Um,
the course asks,
why should style wed Philistia and women and Samsung responds?
This is line two 19 the first I saw at Timnah and she pleased me,
not my parents,
that I sought to wed the daughter of an infidel.
They knew not that what I motioned was of God I knew from intimate impulse and
therefore urge the marriage on that bio occasion.
Hence,
I might begin Israel's deliverance
and,
and I think we're being invited to ask,
well,
how did Samson know that he was motioned of God to marry the woman of Tim?
By what sign did God make this approval?
Gnome and Samson Samson answers our question and his response is an important
one.
I knew from intimate impulse,
wouldn't it be wonderful if we could answer questions like that with such an
answer?
Questions like that with such an answer.
Um,
I knew from intimate impulse,
it's important because this phrase intimate impulse surely implies a sexual it
passion,
a sexual impulse as readily as it does anything like a mysterious impulsion from
God.
And,
and,
and the big question still remains.
How can you tell the difference?
Sampson agonists,
Ds is the only one of Milton's last works to imagine a world in which God is
neither visible or audible.
On some level.
He had been visible in paradise lost and he was no longer visible.
He was audible and paradise regained.
And now he's,
now he's none of those things.
The deity simply doesn't assert himself anywhere,
um,
authoritatively in this text.
And of course,
that's one of the reasons why Milton chose to wrote this,
right?
This piece in the,
in a theatrical form,
a dramatic form in which God couldn't possibly be seen as a character.
And the only evidence we have for the presence of the divine will at all is the
extremely equivocal evidence of Samson's intimate impulse.
Milton won't let us know absolutely whether Samsung is really inspired by God.
You destroyed the Philistines or whether he just or whether he's crazy.
He just thinks he's inspired by God to kill the Philistines.
And Milton knows that there's nothing like in controvertible evidence to prove
that Samson is a divinely inspired freedom fighter and a freedom fighter rather
than a terrorist or what seems at the end of the poem to be something,
I dunno,
we would have to call them something like a suicide bomber.
And this is why.
This is why the critical controversies surrounding Samson agonists,
Geez,
a set of controversies that have been surrounding the poems for about 20 years
now.
Why they really came to a head almost immediately after,
after nine 11,
the Milton can be seen to sanction a single man's destruction of thousands of
people,
an act that might only be imagined to be divinely authorized.
Um,
when there is no evidence in the text that it's absolutely,
definitively divinely authorized head comed to see more troubling than ever.
Um,
after nine 11 and it,
and of course Milton is not anywhere sanctioning mass slaughter,
but he is insisting that there's never anything in the world like definitive
proof of God's authorization of,
of anything.
We just have to believe in our authorization.
And it's,
this is Milton's amazing resume reticence in this regard that has set off that
set off after nine 11,
I kind of panic among certain Milton [inaudible] and John Kerry,
the distinguished Milton hissed at,
at Oxford,
uh,
the Milton hissed at Oxford.
Um,
and,
and you know this from the piece that was included in the packet.
Um,
even John Kerry had been pushed to,
uh,
I dunno,
I think a,
a reasonable,
maybe even a hysterical critical stance toward this text,
uh,
by Milton's unwillingness to proclaim on the question of Samson's,
authority to,
to kill so many people
in Milton's other poems.
And it goes without saying in the real world of all of our everyday lives,
one is simply not permitted to act upon all of one's in most impulses and
desires.
We're,
we're constantly being called upon to be rational and to resist those
temptations for the greater goal of the obedience to the law.
The Sun in paradise regained what was able to begin his work of Israel's
deliverance by,
by suppressing his hunger,
by suppressing his passion.
It was by suppressing even his interest in the beauty of classical civilization.
But,
but Samson who certainly in this text,
something like a type of Christ,
begins Israel's deliverance by acting on his hungers by,
by acting on his passions and desires that the intimate stirring of his loins
might be one of those things energizing his actions.
Uh,
Milton gives us in this poem up a powerful alternative,
a scandalous alternative to the traditional obligation to subordinate one's
desire to the will of God.
And in this place and in this play and this text,
one's deepest ones,
darkest desire,
turns out in fact,
to be the will of God.
That's as shocking as anything else.
It seems to me.
Think of paradise lost.
Milton's great achievement in paradise lost.
And it really was a magnificent achievement,
was to structure the poem as a theodicy.
He took the,
what he took to be the irrational god of the Judeo Christian tradition,
and he remade him into a reasonable and justifiable embodiment of law to a large
extent.
By the time we get to Samsung,
agonists sees it's,
it's almost as if you could feel Milton's relief,
a sigh of relief.
Uh,
now that he's been released from the pressure to write a theodicy,
thank God you can hear Milton and saying,
I don't have to ride it theodicy anymore.
I don't have to justify God anymore.
And at the here at the end of Milton's career,
you,
you have something like an extraordinary release from all of the strictures of
justice and all of the strictures of reason that Milton had set for himself and
that Milton had submitted himself to
according to the Aristotelian theory of,
of tragedy.
The climax of a tragedy is supposed to be the Cathar.
It's supposed to be Cathartic for the viewer.
Um,
or perhaps for the reader originally for the viewer,
it's supposed to purge or to release all of those pent up passions in the
audience.
But I think there's a way in which the climax of Samson agonists,
ds functions as much as a catharsis for the poet as it as it does for the
reader.
Look,
look again,
look again at page five 91.
Uh,
this is line 1647.
I think we have an image here of the,
of this cathartic release.
Um,
as it has been inscribed by Milton into the Po,
into the poem itself.
And within that passage that we just looked at at the very moment that Samson
acts of his own accord and brings the Massey pillars down here at line 1647,
as with the force of winds and waters pent when mountains tremble.
And then he tugged,
he shook,
uh,
w w when Samson,
when Samson Po pulls the pillars down,
it says,
if a damn we're breaking the,
the force of winds and waters that have been pent or penned up have suddenly
been released.
And you can see an emblem,
I think for the powerful release that is allowing his own,
his own religious imagination.
Milton's water has broken.
And it's as if you were giving,
it's as if he were giving birth to yet another fantasy theology.
This theology just being that much more fantastic than anything he had come up
with before.
And this is essentially a theology that Milton's contemporaries would have
called Antinomian.
Um,
he's,
he's generated a text in which divine will is an ever opposed to a human desire.
God's will and man's will or simply the same thing.
A Nice,
nice,
nice work if you can get it.
Now there's there,
there,
there has been another release in the miltonic imagination as well in uh,
in Samson show of strength at the festival of day gone.
You have an act of sacrifice that saves the Hebrews from their Philistine
oppressors and a,
and Samson's sacrifice at the temple has,
has to readers for a long time now.
And I think this seems unmistakable,
um,
has a resemblance to Christ's sacrifice on the cross.
And a lot of biblical commentators in fact in Milton's time agreed that Samson's
action because his arms are outstretched,
um,
was something like a,
a,
a pre figuration of Christ's crucifixion.
And,
and there's something like a sense in which Milton in this poem is allowing
himself and he's really allowing himself for the first time here near the end of
his life to represent this pivotal moment and Christian and Chris and Christian
history,
the crucifixion,
um,
Milton,
like the Bible has Samson's arms outstretched on the Massey pillars as if
indirect imitation of Christ posture on the cross.
Let look at the very beginning of the poem.
Actually look at the little place before the very beginning of the poem.
This is Milton's note on the form of tragedy.
It's on page five 49 of the Hughes.
And this no starts to explain why Milton is writing has chosen this genre,
the genre of tragedy,
dramatic tragedy for his final work.
Um,
and so was a Milton is,
is,
is laboring here to justify his decision to write a tragedy.
And he cites others who have written tragedies themselves.
Um,
this is a little over halfway down.
no,
no.
This is near the bottom of page five.
More 49.
Milton Invokes Augustus Caesar Augustus Caesar also had begun his Ajax,
his tragedy,
Ajax,
but I'm unable to please his own judgment with what he had begun.
Left it unfinished
look,
a couple of sentences down.
Milton invokes,
but true Gd and Greg Gregory Nausea Hanson,
Gregory nausea on Zinn who was able to finish a tragedy.
Gregory nausea hands.
And a father of the church thought it not unbuzz seeming the sanctity of his
person to write a tragedy which he called entitled Christ suffering.
And I think it's clear that Milton is thinking of the genre of tragedy here is
the literary form best suited to the subject of Christ's passion,
Christ's suffering on the cross.
Milton of course we know had tried to represent Christ's suffering on the cross,
uh,
once before,
but just like Augustus Caesar who wasn't able to finish his tragedy,
Ajax,
the young Milton had left his initial attempt at the story of the passion
unfinished.
And perhaps you'll remember the little note that Milton had appended to that
early poem.
The Passion that we read at the beginning of the semester.
The poem just ends abruptly.
You'll remember,
and Milton writes this subject of the crucifixion,
the author finding to be of the above the years he had when he wrote it and
nothing satisfied with what was begun.
Left it unfinished well here at the end of his life.
Finally,
Milton's finally able to finish the unfinished poem,
the Passion Samson Samson agonists.
These ends with that magnificent line and calm of mind.
All passion spent.
And that line speaks on one level to the fact it speaks on many levels,
but on one level it speaks to the fact that Milton has finished the passion that
Milton has finally acquitted himself of the debt that he incurred when he left
that earlier poem,
the passion on finished.
Now we're left to wonder why Milton,
why is he able finally to represent an act of sacrifice,
not unlike Christ's sacrifice on the cross.
Why suddenly is this here to for unrepresented bell event?
Representable and,
and I think Milton is able to complete this representation of the crucifixion
because he was at,
he's been able entirely to reimagine the dynamics of sacrifice.
Now in the New Testament,
in the gospel of John,
we're told that God so loved the world that he gave his only begotten son to
save that world.
The father willingly sacrificed the sun,
but in Samsung agonist,
he's the hero sacrifices himself.
Samson sacrifices himself of his own accord as he tells us in fulfillment of his
own private motives.
In fact.
And,
and it's only once Milton can supply the act of sacrifice with something like a
complete sense of self determination,
then he can finally,
he can admit it into his poetic cannon.
I think this problem is,
is completely overwhelmed by events that,
uh,
that had previously been left unfinished or suppressed in,
in Milton's earlier works.
And,
and,
and if I'm right about that,
we shouldn't be surprised to see that the resurfacing of another desire that had
so consumed Milton at earlier stages in his career.
And that is the desire for fame.
You remember what Milton had written to his friend,
Dia,
Dottie and 1637 Milton had written,
you asked me what I think,
what I'm thinking of,
so help me God.
So help me God and immortality of fame.
Uh,
th th the young 29 year old Milton had written,
but he soon corrected himself and enlisted us.
Fame was denigrated as that last infirmity of the noble mind and in paradise
regained its denigrated even further.
Fame was a temptation offered by,
by Satan to the son of God,
that of course the son of God was able to reject without wincing.
But here,
here at the end of Samson,
the prospect of earthly fame I'm talking about good old fashioned secular fame
is granted the dead Samson and it's granted to him without the slightest apology
and it's,
and it Samson's earthly father Manoa who labors to ensure his son's fame.
Look at the last page of the poem.
This is page five 93.
Okay.
Uh,
Manoa,
says at the top of the page,
I will send for all my kindred,
all my friends to fetch him.
Him is the dead body of Samsung.
All my friends to fetch him hints and solemnly attend with silent obstacle and
funeral train home to his father's house.
And,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll interrupt myself here just for a moment because I'm going to ask you to
think of the possible counterpoint that that line that I've just read has,
uh,
with the,
with the end of paradise,
regained home to his mother house private.
He returned.
Um Manoa,
continues there,
will I build him a monument and plant it round with shade of Laurel Evergreen
and branching poem with all his trophies,
hung and acts enrolled in copious legend or sweet lyrics song.
Now,
the shade of Laurel Evergreen is not,
uh,
is not an honor,
typically bestowed upon the great biblical heroes,
but it is an honor bestowed upon great poets,
at least in the classical tradition.
That's why we have the phrase poet laureate.
And you having this incredibly moving tribute that monster that Manoa has given
Samson the promise of eternal fame.
That has been the desire of great poets.
As long as there have been great poets that the monument built for Samson here
is something like a displaced version of Milton's own monument.
Maybe this is a monument that can compete with the live long monument that
shakes that Milton had imagined.
Uh,
that was the monument of Shakespeare,
Shakespeare's tomb of which the young Milton had written in his first published
poem.
Now,
as you can see,
as you can see from the bottom of the handout,
from the passage from one of the earliest biographies of Milton,
and this is also included in the Hughes.
Milton at his death was,
was,
was buried at the churchyard at cripple gate.
We're about 30 years before he had by chance also in turn his father
like,
like Samson's body.
At the time of his death,
the body of John Milton was returned as it were,
home to his father's house.
Now we're told here very,
very carefully that this happened by chance,
but it's surely not a leap to assume that Milton was himself responsible for the
instructions,
uh,
of,
for his place of burial and that he was thinking on some level of the burial of
Samsung when,
when he arranged him to have himself buried next to his father or near his
father.
It's as if by returning to the father's house,
Milton could guarantee for himself the promise of fame that had been bestowed
upon Samson.
Look at the middle quotation on the handout as a,
as John Aubrey wrote in his life of Milton,
Milton had during his lifetime achieved a considerable measure of fame.
He didn't have to wait.
Uh,
he didn't have to wait for after his death.
And according to Aubrey for several forerunners,
and I love this detail,
it's wild to imagine for a lot of foreigners coming over it into England in the
17th century,
the only inducement to make the trip was to see John Milton.
And more specifically the inducement for foreigners to come to England was to
see the house and chamber where he was born.
It's like a tourist attraction,
uh,
this as of course,
the father's house and in his life,
Milton,
Milton's,
the,
the Milton home had become this,
this,
uh,
this Mecca,
just like the one that Manawa is planning the planning for,
for,
for Samson.
Now,
one of the reasons I think,
uh,
one of the reasons for which we love or for which we hate the Po,
the poetry or there any,
anything about John Milton involves the degree to which he wrote about himself.
And Milton,
I think more than any other poet,
certainly any other poet before him has invited,
uh,
I think a unique fascination with the intimate habits of his mind.
And,
and,
and for some of us even,
uh,
as a unique fascination in his daily life at home.
And,
and I think the desire of Milton's readers are a lot of Milton's readers to
imagine the poet at home,
um,
is,
is a,
is an interesting one.
And at least that's one way to explain the strange and for me the wonderful
artifact that I photocopied for you.
And it's on the other side of the,
it's on the other side of the handout.
This is a document that I used to,
it's a version of a document that I used to receive every couple of years,
um,
from the friends of Milton's cottage,
a group in America.
And this is the form letter representing the,
the now longstanding movement to raise funds in order to restore what is the
only surviving house,
uh,
that,
that Milton actually lived in.
And it's something like,
you know,
uh,
Milton's cottage.com you can,
you can,
you can find information about how to get there and so on and so forth if you're
interested.
This is the cottage at childfund St Giles that Milton had moved to in the 1660s
when the,
when the plague was sweeping through London and,
and the organization dedicated to restoring this house is known as the friends
of Milton's cottage.
And the president of this group,
as you can see,
was,
um,
I don't believe he's the president anymore,
was one,
uh,
Dr. Ronald G.
Shaffer.
And He,
and he's,
he used to send Milton lists,
just this,
this fundraising letter every few years.
And I,
I mentioned this,
this curious artifact,
not at all because I'm asking you to give to the,
to the cause.
I think the cottage is probably in good shape at this point.
Um,
but I,
I get,
I offer it to you to give you a sense of the peculiar impact that John Milton
has had on his readers.
And I think that impact can be measured by something like the almost pagan
desire to memorialize the physical presence of this heroic poet that has seized
so many have his readers.
Now of course,
the ostensible project here as you can see from the handout is simply to restore
Milton's home.
But I'm convinced that there's something there.
There's something profound or going on and it's a,
it's,
it's the deeper project,
um,
informing the Labor of Labor,
a labor of love,
like a restoration projects such as this one.
And I think that the underlying desire really behind such a project is,
and of course this would only be unconscious or it's a kind of fantasy project,
but it's the desire to return Milton to his home that the friends of Milton's
cottage or just like the friends that Manawa mentions in that final speech at
line 1730,
I will send for all my kindred,
all my friends to fetch him,
hence home to his father's house.
And I think it was just,
I,
it,
it chokes me up.
There's something.
So moving about Mona was plea and there's something for me moving about doctor
Ronald g Schaefer's a plea.
And that's,
and the relation for me at least is,
is that there's,
there's something about Milton just as there's something about Samson that
resists ascension.
Resist transcendence despite all of the talk of heaven.
The actual corporeal body seems so stubbornly to,
to remain,
uh,
that you remember that that was the case enlisted us to a large extent and it's
this case in the,
in the final poem as well written,
written 30 years later.
And I think there's something profoundly miltonic about our own materialist
interests in,
in Milton and interest that keeps coming back,
keeps coming back to the bodily facts of his life and his home and his everyday,
everyday surroundings,
but more generally than that.
And more importantly than that,
um,
an interest in the material facts,
the fact of materiality,
of everyone's life and of life itself,
the importance,
the value and the beauty of the physical is one of the things,
uh,
that we,
that we learned that we get from a reading of,
of John Milton.
Now,
if I have been,
if I have been unorthodox and some of these lectures and IB,
uh,
deeply ashamed to think that I haven't been at least a little over the top,
um,
it's been in my sharing with you,
uh,
my fascination with Milton's life.
Then Milton's biography or,
um,
with,
uh,
well actually I think it's my interest in Milton's own extraordinary tendency to
write autobiographically.
Um,
there's an unparalleled self absorption at the heart of Milton's writing and
this sublime self absorption.
I think,
um,
of of so many of these texts demand some sing,
like an equally passionate absorption in the life of the person who authored
those texts,
like the foreigners who traveled to England during Milton's own lifetime.
I have found myself pursuing Milton with a kind of,
and maybe it's creepy,
maybe it's not.
You can,
you can decide,
but with a certain voyeurism,
um,
it's something in me has always wanted to,
to peer into Milton's house and chamber or at least to think of these poems in
some way as Milton's house and chamber.
And if I've managed to,
to arouse in you even the slightest tendency to this sort of critical voyeurism,
then on some level I feel that I will have a,
that I will have accomplished something.
And so I want to end this semester by,
by thanking you for the enormous efforts that you put into this class for
electric class.
I know that this requires,
um,
a lot of work and I want to thank you more generally for the work that you have
performed.
Um,
and I,
I take this work to be the intellectual equivalent of the restoration project
undertaken by Doctor Ronald g Schaefer.
Um,
the work that you've performed in restoring the greatest,
if not the home,
then the greatest of all English poets,
um,
himself.
So I will see you all.
I will see you all at the exam.
But before,
before I sign off,
we have to think our two perfectly magnificent teaching fellows who I am going
to embarrass by asking them to stand up just so we can applaud them and
acknowledge them.
David Chlorella and Matt build ideas.